hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of the Greinke chess classic 2019
it's Magnus Carlsen versus Maxine
vishaya Grove and like we mentioned in
the previous video Carson has well he
pretty much only needs a draw against
Maxine holographic Lynch first place
ahead of Fabiana Caruana but if he loses
to Maxine Buffalo Grove and Cora wanna
beat Slevin Oregon then there will be a
playoff as they will be tied for first
place so uh it's an important game and
well let's just check it out we don't
have any footage as the game finished
quite early but Crossan does have the
white pieces and he opens with c4 he
again goes for his English with c5 by
Maxine the symmetrical English we have
g3 g6 Bishop to g2 and Bishop to g7 nice
to see three just keeping the symmetry
going Knight to c6 Knight to f3 and the
d6 now we have castles by Carlsen Bishop
to f5 and now comes h3 and it's it's the
same line that Carson already used the
last year in the world the rapid
championship but we are going to mention
that after Carson deviates from it now
and just Knight to f6 continues
developing d3 we have castles by Maxine
and now in the 2018 world the rapid
championship cross and played rook to be
one here against even some god alloh PES
in the sankt-petersburg
world rapid championship as we've said
but here we have Bishop to e3 look to be
one and E for our known moves in this
position but the move cost in place here
Bishop d3 is a new move and it's well
it's hard to say if he found it over the
board or or prepared it but I did catch
a glimpse of the interview after the
game they did not discuss this but okay
a six just preparing some perhaps future
expansion on the Queen side it would be
five cousin goes for Queen to d2 this
nice special queen battery aims for h6
to exchange the dark square bishop and
here we have already an interesting move
by Maxime maybe because Crossan went for
this move that was not played before or
maybe he was just impulsive or something
but cross I mentioned in an interview
after the game that Maxime often likes
to sacrifice
here and there for a nice initiative and
this is exactly what he does here we
have b5 here and it's a pawn sacrifice
we have pawn captures pawn captures
Knight captures here Queen to a5
offering a trade of Queens and now comes
Knight to c3 and it's a it's a similar
pawn sacrifice so like you would have in
a bank whole gambit or something where
you would have this strong dragon here
the the rook would come let's say to be
eight and then the two rooks would be
very strong here and the two rooks and
the a and B file and the bishop
controlling this diagonal will be
compensation for the pawn so it's a
perhaps a similar idea but okay here
Maxine goes rook 8 to b8 now he doesn't
bring the other rook to b8 he wants to
bring this rook over to see it and
Carlson develops the rooks accordingly
with rook F the c1 I expecting the other
book to come to see it rook F to see it
and now b3 so what's Maxim's
compensation for the pawn well he his
pieces are much more active so if he can
make use of this then the pond has not
been sacrificed in vain we have E 5 by
Maxine and now Bishop to h6 you want to
get rid of this very strong Bishop nice
the d4 now going for this Knight
captures on f3
we have Bishop captures now not
capturing immediately but first Knight
captures on f3 with check and now if you
capture with the bishop then Bishop
captures an h3 so we have to capture
with the pawn now comes King captures on
g7 and here Carlsen immediately goes for
f4 he wants to get rid of his double
pawn and create a weakness here in in
blacks position we have Queen to a6 now
attacking the d3 pawn twice and Carlsen
just captures on e5 f captures on e5
with D captures on e5 and now comes
Knight to a4 offering maxime to go into
an endgame but now it's highly
unfavorable for him if captures captures
and captures you're just gonna capture
on c5 and you get this end game where a
cousin is up a pawn but most importantly
he has two connected passed pawns and it
would be well it would be winning for
white so after Knight to a4 with Knights
the d7 guarding the c5 pawn and now
crossing goes for rook to see
three not not a very active square for
the rook but again it gets the job done
similarly to the to the Caruana game we
have looked to be four by Maxine and the
now comes G for pushing the bush back
Bishop to e6 and only now Knight
captures on c5 and this goes into a very
long series of exchanges Knight captures
on c5 rook captures on c5 and now if you
capture then just Queen captures here so
at least Maxine wants to grab a pawn
before before finishing of the trade
rook captures on b3 now comes rook
captures on c8 Bishop captures on CH the
Queen has to remain on the a file to
keep pinning the pawn now you cannot
capture because of Queen captures rook
on a1 and here we have looked the c1 by
Carlsen black gets the d3 pawn we have
rook captures on d3 the Queen has to
keep an eye on the bishop here and now
comes the Queen - II - nicely pinning
the pawn here and it's a very dangerous
position the the rook is pinned well not
yet as the bishop also defends the Queen
but the Queen also defends the a to pawn
and there's the threat of winning the e5
pawn so what do you play here one one of
the ideas is that the bishop can't
really stay there because Bishop to f1
would win the rook here so Maxine
immediately prepares to defended the
rook if needed with Bishop to e6 and he
has to give away the e5 pawn we have
Queen captures on e5 with check King to
g8 and now comes Luke to be won by
column as the queen is slicing all the
way here controlling this diagonal rook
to b8 would be a very nice idea Luke the
d8 by Maxine preventing this and now
comes Luke to b8 nevertheless so there's
no time to be grabbing pawns or anything
as rook captures rook it would be would
be deadly so rook captures and e8 Queen
captures on b8 with check King to g7 and
now you could go for something like
Queen B to check its f6 and a3 to defend
you're a pawn this way but Carson finds
a much nicer way to do it instead of
going for Queen B to check he plays
Bishop to d5 and it gets the job done
and also goes into a queen opponent game
with cost and being up upon so Maxine
trade with Bush of captures 25 check f6
and now queen picks up the bishop back
while defending the a to pawn with h5 by
Maxine G captures G captures and now
comes Queen to d7 check King to g6 and
now just a four as the Queen from d7 is
protecting the pawn here we have Queen -
E - mock seems only hope here is the
maybe get some sort of a perpetual but
Crossin doesn't allow that we have Queen
to d5 and could the Queen from d5
controls everything I controls the d1
square so no Queen d1 checked followed
by Queen captures and a4 as possible
also controls all of the light squares
here so when King finally comes to g2
black will not be able to deliver check
and the D H three-point controls the g4
square so the Queen is unable to deliver
check from there so there there are no
checks to be given you can go Queen e1
check but the den just King g2 and the
king will be very safe there
so f5 here by black we have a five by
Carson he starts pushing his passport
we have f4 and now comes King to g2 not
allowing f3 to be pushed of course we
have King to h6 by Maxine and now Queen
to f5 just keeping an eye on that King
not allowing him to come any closer
and now if the black Queen moves cousin
can even attack the f4 pawn with his
king and win it that way and he will be
up three points so Queen to c4 by black
and now just King to f3 as we already
said this is there was no better move
for black and it was in this position
I'll move 43 that Maxine for sherrilyn
Grove resigned the game as there is
nothing to be done here everything is
protected black can't really make any
threats if you do any check you deliver
will result in King captures on f4 again
everything is protected you were three
points to one point this is a completely
winning endgame of course both Maxime
and Carson notice
so after this King to have to remove
Maxime or sherrilyn Grove resigned the
game so I don't have the cross table and
the final standings as some of the games
are still being played but what we do
know is that Carson is definitely the
sole leader of the tournament followed
by Fabian Khurana who is second and
Maxie Marshall a graph here clinches a
third place even after losing this last
game to Carlson and I don't know
will most likely check out another game
from the final round and then we're
gonna check out the standings to be sure
but I did prepare some statistics here
and these are the live ratings of the
top 20 players so as you can see Carlsen
in number one well his official rating
is 28 62 but he won 17 points in this
during this month so it all has to be
accounted for at the beginning of the
next month and as I don't think he will
be playing any more classical games
since it's the 29th of April that I'm
recording this 2862 + 70 that's 28 79 so
that will be his new classical rating 28
79 his all-time best was 2882 so he's
three points short to reaching his
all-time best and yeah if he continues
playing like this he will reach his
all-time best and maybe maybe even be
the first chess player ever to reach
2900 I mean it's not really all that big
of a deal because all chess players will
at one point to reach 20 2900 because as
more players are registered more more
players are getting into chess a lot
more rating is fed into the rating
system and of course at the at the far
top the ratings increase for example the
top Grandmaster now would be almost 2900
- like Carson and then Fischer's era it
would be 2700 would be the highest top
so the the top ratings have shifted but
getting 2900 in this day and age would
be an extreme accomplishment so we'll
we'll see what happens if he if Carlsen
continues playing like this then I'm
sure it could very well happen for him
but yeah yeah that's the game crossing
again proves that he he reached his top
form by winning the tata steel
tournament by winning the Shanker the
Kashima memorial and now winning rank HS
classic with I believe seven and a half
out of nine that's that's insane that's
six wins and three draws so that's
really really really crazy but yeah I do
hope you enjoyed it like I said we're
probably gonna cover another game and
now we're gonna rest up a bit before the
start of the great
grand Chester and we will be continuing
our Capablanca saga of checking up on
your suggestions and and such I would
like to thank Stephen Porter Charles
cotton Miguel Martinez Chopin and Baron
of Murdoch for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous video serie think all for
watching and I will see you soon
with everything I've already mentioned
and the be sure to check out some of the
links in the description below
impressions from the previous round some
nice interviews and whatever I managed
to come up with under green GHS classic
YouTube channel yeah thank you I will
see you soon have an excellent rest of
your day